so we've been following two things with
great interest number one is
um Tuesday's gubernatorial election in
Virginia very important race it's
Democrat Terry McAuliffe against
absolutely radical outrageous extremist
Republican Glenn Younkin and not only is
that an important race for Virginia
keeping Virginia blue but it also it's
at least being theorized is important
maybe in terms of how it would affect
the politics of the area including
neighboring West Virginia and Democratic
senator Joe manchin's willingness to
concede more or there's all these
different ways in which it's important
but it's a very important race number
two we've been following the new trend
it I mean I think at this point it's a
trend of Republicans saying if we don't
win it's rigged if we don't win it's
rigged we saw this with the 2020
presidential election
um and we'll look at some other examples
Republicans are already claiming fraud
in the Virginia gubernatorial election
they're already doing it fraud exactly
they are now saying it sounds like we're
hearing that Democrats are already
cheating we're going to look at a video
now of the Virginia Republican state
senator Amanda Chase she was interviewed
on real America's voice outside the
Beltway the day before yesterday I
believe it was and she says uh Democrats
are cheating they're already cheating
folks they're doing it every race now
ahead of time Democrats are already
cheating unless we win if we win we won
despite the cheating if we lose we lost
because of the cheating take a look look
um I'm all about fighting for the truth
too and and sometimes unfortunately we
can't always rely on the media I wanted
to go there I wanted to feel it I wanted
to see it a picture's worth a thousand
words I know how Democrats are are
cheating right and that's already we
don't even have any votes counted yet
information has been given to the
younken campaign well they're going to
try to do it in Fairfax County
reports today that people are going to
vote and they have never done a mail-in
ballot ever wow is that even legal yet
when they went to cast their ballot they
were told no we've already mailed you a
mail-in ballot and so we're already
looking into that that's so again those
are assertions about which there could
be multiple different explanations it is
not evidence of cheating it is not
evidence of Fraud and it's not evidence
that it's Democrats that are doing
anything that could even if true that
could be happening to the same number of
Democrats and Republicans it's three
layers of nonsense so that's why we told
everybody in Virginia vote early so that
couldn't happen the earlier you voted
they couldn't do it
did you notice that now it's voters now
the right is saying vote as early as you
possibly can so this is the new thing
right before between the 2020
presidential and the California
gubernatorial recall we said this is
what they're going to do all the time
they did it with the California
gubernatorial recall remember when Larry
Elder the Republican candidate was asked
the day before the election will you
commit to accepting the results and he
wouldn't we knew they were going to do
it there as well Larry Elder the leading
Republican candidate would not commit to
accepting the results of the election
again whether or not you win or lose
will you accept the results of the
election tomorrow right I think we all
ought to be looking at election
Integrity no matter whether you're a
Democrat an independent or republican
let's all make sure that the election is
a fair election told us all work
together no matter what the results are
they make sure that the results are
valid unless you want everybody who
voted should have voted let's all do
that together is that a commitment to
accept the results of the election
tomorrow let's all do that together
let's all work together on both sides of
the aisle to make sure that the election
is a fair election and so he didn't say
he would accept the results Donald Trump
did the exact same thing a few days
earlier before the California
gubernatorial recall on Newsmax I think
this was on Newsmax saying uh it's all
rigged it's all rigged the Democrats are
cheating well it's probably rigged
they're sending out all balance it's all
uh the the ballots are you know mail out
mail-in ballots in fact I guess you even
have a case where you can make your own
ballot I made one on construction paper
with crayons when that happens uh
nobody's gonna win except uh these
Democrats so you know look they're
they're very good the one thing they're
good at is rigging elections so I
predict it's a rigged election let's see
how it turns out so that was ahead of
the California gubernatorial recall of
course Gavin Newsom won by such insane
numbers that it became difficult to
claim that it was actually rigged uh but
they still did it so this is the move
now this is the move and the first step
is Terry McAuliffe has to win Virginia
and Tuesday night starting at 8 pm
Eastern maybe a little bit before I will
be doing live election results of what
is happening there as well as the New
Jersey election we've got some mayoral
elections in different parts of the
country of consequence a lot of
different things
that's step one number two is really
thinking about the long-term impact of
this that they are now using if they
didn't like the results or they predict
they might not win it's it was rigged it
was stolen Etc not only because of the
systemic risk that it presents in terms
of just denouncing
um irrationally the basic institutions
of democracy in the United States but
it could lead to a sort of boy who cried
wolf situation where at a certain point
they actually rig an election and steal
it and when we point it out they can
come in and say guys we've been calling
out rigged elections for years and you
never paid attention until now because
you know they'll do it if given that
opportunity so concerning for a number
of reasons they're doing it in Virginia
as well one of our sponsors is sheath
underwear it's summer right now in the
northern hemisphere it's hot it's humid
many of the men in my audience know
about the discomfort that can come with
this with traditional underwear the
sweating the chafing the sticking not
fun and that's what sheath underwear has
solved sheath has designed men's boxer
briefs with multiple ergonomic
compartments built into the front of the
underwear which keeps everything
separate dry cool and comfortable all
day long sheath has re-released to
limited edition Styles Flower of Life
with a stylish flower pattern and bold
geometric waistband the other limited
edition style is the mesh air flow
especially designed to be lightweight
and promote extra coolness and
breathability give sheath underwear a
try I've had a great experience with it
I think you will too you can find the
link underneath this video and don't
forget to use promo code Pacman for 20
off